[Music]
the world of superhero movies has always
had an intriguing aspect to it and its
fan base and has been huge for decades
nowadays every child knows everything
about his or her favorite hero with the
classics batman
spiderman and superman being
particularly popular of course
the universe of superhero movies is
shared by three studios
disney with the mcu and its
ex-competitor fox sony with spider-man
venom and co and finally warner with all
the dc movies
today we want to give you an overview of
9 superhero movies worth looking forward
to
so enjoy our latest originals episode
the first marvel movie since spider-man
far from home is titled black widow and
marks the beginning of phase four of the
mcu
natasha romanov aka black widow fought
her last spectacular battle in avengers
end game
through her selfless dedication to the
avengers she secured a place in the
hearts of many fans
her appearance however leaves quite a
few questions regarding her backstory
which is why marvel's black widow after
several postponements of the release
date
now wants to address and clarify exactly
these questions
this may the focus is on her activities
as a spy and hit woman for the russian
secret service kgb
however romanov is not the only black
widow there
for instance she befriends the young
yelena belova encounters with melinda
and alexey jostakov who has read
guardian was something like the russian
captain america
also play a major role in the life of
the young natasha romanov
the cast is pretty top notch with
florence pew as yelena scarlett
johansson's black widow david harbour as
alexis shostakov and rachel weiss as
melina vostokov
behind the camera 52 year old kate
shortland will be directing
we are definitely excited about the
startup phase 4 of the mcu and are
already looking forward to the expected
release date of black widow on may 7th
2021 our next film is called morbius
from sony
the story revolves around michael
morbius a biochemist played by geralito
who suffers from a rare blood disease
and tries to cure himself through
self-experimentation
of course the whole thing goes horribly
wrong and morbius contracts a form of
vampirism
in the comics this is accompanied by
typical vampire traits such as rampant
blood consumption and aversion to
sunlight the ability to fly
and superhuman fighting and healing
abilities on his somewhat tragic path
through life he later meets spider-man
and joins the legion of monsters
in addition to his existence as a
blood-sucking vampire he is also a
brilliant scientist who can even call
nobel prize for biochemistry his own by
the end of spider-man 3 at the latest
peter parker will finally return to sony
which will make a long-awaited clash
between morbius
and peter parker feasible for fans the
upcoming morbius will be directed by
daniel espinoza with the release day set
for march 19
2021 the next movie on our list is
marvel shangshi and the legend
of the ten rings the focus is on chiang
shi who is also called the master of
kung fu
in contrast to the big names like
captain america or spider-man chiang shi
is still relatively
unknown in the mcu as early as his
childhood the son of fu manchu already
trained in martial arts
he's thus superior to many mcu
colleagues thanks to his perfect mastery
of a wide variety of martial arts
even without superpowers it then turns
out in the comics that chengxi's father
is actually a villain who wants to take
over the world
whether the film takes up this
circumstance on a one-to-one basis is of
course a different question
the cast so far includes simul us shanxi
jolly liang chiwai as mandarin as well
as aquafina ronnie chiang michel hiwa
and he had unknown roles
the marvel blockbuster will be directed
by destin daniel [ __ ] who had his
breakthrough with the indie hit short
term 12
solent heroes the release of shanxi and
the legend of the tan rings is scheduled
for july 9th
2021 fairly little is known about our
next film doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness yet
in the recent past the headlines
surrounding the sequel to 2016's doctor
strange have tended to revolve around
the fact that
original director scott derrickson left
his post shortly before filming began
causing uncertainty in the production
fortunately however
the right man for the sequel was soon
found with sam raimi which is why the
loss of derek's as a director remains
bearable the cast currently only
includes benedict cumberbatch as dr
steven strange elizabeth olsen has won
the maximoff civital eg04 as mordo and
benedict wong
as wong an alleged villain is also said
to have been found and named nightmare
though this has not yet been officially
confirmed as producers by the way axe
director scott derricks and marvel boss
kevin feige are also still involved
after a recent postponement of the film
the new release date for doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is set for
march 25th
2022 among many other films the sequel
to 2018's box office hit venom called
venom let there be carnage is coming up
this year
in the second part sony's anti-hero will
meet the villain cletus cassidy aka
carnage who was previously teased in the
first
part just like venom carnage is an alien
symbian that affects cassidy and gives
him even more mighty powers than his
counterpart
but that's not all the villain shriek
also has a say in the matter and
attempts to give venom a hard time with
a superhuman sonic powers
with tom hardy as venom michelle
williams is annoying woody harrelson as
cletus cassidy and naomi harris is
shriek
the nude movie should be more than well
cast there will be no stranger to the
director's chair either with the
director being andy
serkis you can find out exactly how the
confrontation between
venom and carnage will end as from june
25th
2021 in a cinema new you
we still have to wait over a year until
the release of the batman
since the dc fandom in august in
particular it has become clear to many
fans that the wait will most likely be
worth it after yet another postponement
a few months ago
according to director matt reeves the
new blockbuster with the dark knight
will be a mixture of mystery thriller
and detective story
by solving many murders the still young
bruce wayne then comes into contact with
a wide variety of super villains
with zoe kravitz's selena kyle paul dano
as the riddler and colin farrell's the
penguin
the dark knight already has quite a few
adversaries ahead of him
and those are just the most serious
threats bringing all these characters
together is certainly no
easy task but according to reeves it's
one of the most challenging and exciting
aspects of the new film
however the whole thing is not meant to
be a real origin story because reeves is
not interested in showing how bruce
becomes batman but rather how he copes
as a newcomer in the hostile world of
gotham city
based on what the people involved say
the story will be very close to the
comics
judging by the emphasis on batman's
ability as a detective
we are definitely eager to find out how
max reeves and his team will implement
the new story of the batman and we are
looking forward to the release on march
4th
2022 the now fourth
thor film is called love and thunder and
will be released shortly before the
batman in 2022
star director taika waititi is
responsible for the script and direction
while the cast includes natalie portman
as jane foster
tessa thompson as valkyrie chris
hemsworth as thor
and christian bale as the new villain so
far it is unclear whether there will be
a reunion with tom hiddleston as loki
after all he is currently still busy
with his own mcu series
meanwhile in an interview with yahoo
actress natalie portman revealed more
details about her character mighty thor
she said that she started exercising
since her character in the film is
supposed to be
very well toned she also confirmed that
in thor love and thunder jane foster has
to cope with her existence as a
superhero
and a cancer patient at the same time in
contrast to portman's casual chit chat
director taika waititi has so far held
back on confirming the kansas storyline
if porkman's statement is true it would
give the story significantly more depth
since it would make the boundary between
superheroine and ordinary mortal
far more multifaceted the release date
for thor
love and thunder is expected to be on
february 18 2022 even before the release
of suicide squad in 2016 it was clear to
those responsible that they would
produce
a sequel after a chaotic back and forth
with the filming and the departure of
david iris director
clarity really only arose when filming
was to begin in september 2019 under the
new direction of james gunn
but since the dc fandom it is now
officially quite clear who will be in
which role in front of the camera
returning from the first part will be
margot robbie as harley quinn joel
kinnaman as rick flack viola davis as
amanda waller and
jay cartney as captain boomerang new
additions will include idris alba as
bloodsport john cena as peacemaker david
desmelchian
as polka dot man and many others
apparently even thought director taika
waititi will be playing a yet unknown
role
unfortunately as for the storyline so
far they are not as forthcoming as with
the announcement of the cast
all we know is that james gunn sees the
project as kind of intellectual sequel
to the original comic book series
therefore it doesn't seem necessary to
have seen the first part of the suicide
squad
the movie is expected to release on
august 4th 2021
now we come to the third part of the
homecoming series with a still untitled
name
spider-man 3. if you haven't seen
spider-man far from home yet then you
should take a short break
the content is of course primarily about
tom holland's new life as an
outed superhero particularly tricky is
the fact that not only does the whole
world know his identity but
everybody also believes him to be a
villain spider-man 3 will be directed by
john
watts returning to the roles will be tom
holland as peter parker
zendaya as mj and marisa tomei as may
parker
the signing of jaime foxx as the villain
electro caused
quite a stir after all he's actually
part of the sony universe and not the
mcu
to what extent the two universes will
collide and whether the film will even
lay the foundation for a brand new sony
universe
can be found out as of december 17 2021
and that's it for today's originals
episode now it's your turn
which movie are you looking forward to
the most and do you think its release
date is realistic
leave us a comment and see you next time
[Music]
foreign